i called round
everyone said they were busy well to be
honest i didn't feel much like
celebrating anyway
you don't want to waste your precious
birthday fran
waiting to get home i can hear
everything
k-i-l-l him yeah and i can spell
just a couple of hot babes coming loose
[Music]
torture isn't really our thing we just
like a nice clean kill
my personal trainer says i have the pain
threshold of someone in a medically
induced
coma right bang
are you the stripper i ordered did you
water a stripper no the human spider
you got someone here from the agency
already i'm not from the agency your
agency has a guy with a bag over his
head who orders him
finally somebody said ah i agree look he
makes like
10 times more than me as well i just
can't understand it
[Music]
graves always takes so much longer to
dig than you think that they
you guys aren't very good at this area
[Applause]
we're just trying to do our job why
don't we pull you up you can get warm
and then we'll kill you in a civilized
[Applause]
manner
you